l'incendié bonjour bonjour vous êtes la
nouvelle directrice des établissements
du groupe renault en ile de france
merci de nous recevoir ici au
technocentre de guyancourt
le premier site de recherche et
développement automobile en europe dont
vous avez de fait la direction
vous êtes en poste depuis le 1er avril
2020 pourquoi avez vous accepté cette
fonction
alors effectivement je suis directrice
établissements d'île de france de
renault c'est qu'ils comptent en fait
seize mille collaborateurs
c'est une grande responsabilité et
patrons d'établissements c'est aussi
partager la vision d'entreprise
la compagnie notamment par le dialogue
social et c'est vraiment permettre à
tous les collaborateurs de donner le
meilleur d'eux-mêmes pour atteindre les
objectifs de l'entreprise
ici à onze mille salariés 1 quelle
orientation vous souhaitez donner à
votre direction
alors en fait qu'est-ce que c'est
finalement le rôle d'un patron
d'établissement
c'est à la fois de garantir je dirais la
conformité réglementaire d'assurer la
protection des données d'assurer la
sécurité des collaborateurs c'est aussi
de donner les meilleures conditions de
travail possibles à nos salariés
par exemple dans le cadre de la gestion
de la crise convient de 19 c'est ce
qu'on sait ce qu'on a fait mais met en
place tout le protocole sanitaire et
puis c'est également être ambassadeur de
l'entreprise et travailler à l'extérieur
avec les acteurs socio économiques qui
nous entoure et enfin c'est aussi gérer
les crises
comme je disais la plus récente étant
celle de covidien
quelle orientation vous allez donner
justement par rapport à la gestion de
cette crise vous avez des exemples à
nous donner alors ce qu'on a fait signer
un protocole qui a été établi dans
l'entreprise pour tout le groupe
et nous on a adapté en fait au
technocentre donc est ce qu'on a fait on
a voulu préserver la sécurité donc on a
demandé par exemple le port obligatoire
du masque chirurgical sur site
on a également mis en conformité tous
nos systèmes de climatisation
la distanciation sociale on a réorganisé
totalement la restauration pour à la
fois permettre aux gens de se restaurer
également de respecter le protocole
sanitaire
et puisqu'on a fait aussi c'est qu'on a
optimisé l'utilisation du télétravail
d'autant qu'en fait on organise des
retours sur site et par rotation de
manière à avoir toujours maximum 30 %
des collaborateurs sur site qui puisse
travailler parce que il ya des choses
qu'on ne peut pas faire non plus bien au
télétravail mais en même temps qu'on les
protège parce que c'est la santé qui
nous préoccupe au premier plan ici
l'activité c'est autour de l'innovation
dans le secteur automobile les défis du
monde de demain c'est le véhicule
autonome le véhicule électrique on voit
derrière nous le le véhicule électrique
du groupe renault la zoé
quel regard vous portez sur ces deux
sujets qui sont les principaux sujets de
préoccupation ici au technocentre
renault de guyancourt
alors effectivement on est dans
l'industrie automobile confronté à une
vraie rupture à une transition
écologique également et donc on a besoin
de nous adapter et c'est ici finalement
qu'on va concevoir des véhicules qui
vont nous permettre de respecter ces
défis de man renault a été précurseur
sur le véhicule électrique donc
effectivement vous par grezzo et voilà
qui fait beaucoup de ventes en france et
en europe et donc pour nous c'est
vraiment clé de continuer sur cette
lancée
après mon rôle moi je suis pas ingénieur
mon rôle c'est le rôle de patron
d'établissement aisément de permettre
que nos ingénieurs développent ici au
technocentre
ce qui nous permettra de faire face aux
défis de demain qu'est ce qui se passe
ici au technocentre autour de ces deux
défis l'un autour des cons soit
finalement les moteurs les moteurs qui
vont nous permettre donc le moteur
électrique la batterie la gestion de la
batterie
on a également donc ici ça me peu connu
mais un atelier de prototypage
en fait on a une usine ici au
technocentre qui nous permet de préparer
en fait les prototypes véhicule on a
également toute la recherche amont
notamment vous parlez du véhicule
autonome du véhicule connecté et c'est
ce qui nous permet de danse 8 développer
les véhicules dans le monde entier par
rapport à 7
activité haute valeur ajoutée qu on veut
maintenir en france un dossier dont vous
avez dû vous saisir aussi depuis votre
prise de fonction c'est le programme de
rénovation du technocentre le programme
le tcr à la fois sur le bâtiment
existant mais aussi la construction d'un
nouveau bâtiment comment vous êtes
saisis de ce dossier là alors on a
évidemment repris ce programme dans le
cadre de de nos contraintes financières
qui ont été évidemment aggravé par la
crise qu'ovide 19
donc en fait l'importance en fait de ce
programme c'est la modernisation de nos
installations mais également la qualité
de vie au travail et les espaces bureaux
et une orientation vers plus de
collaboratif également vraiment pour
être à la page
en fait en termes d'implantation donc on
est en train de revoir ce programme pour
permettre son financement
revoir le schéma directeur en tenant
compte également de ce qui s'est passé
finalement d'une plus grande utilisation
du télétravail sans doute dans le futur
qui va nous amener à imaginer la
solution du travail de dollars vous êtes
sur un territoire c'est le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines deuxième pôle
économique d'ile-de-france beaucoup
d'acteurs autour autour de vous
notamment dans le secteur de
l'automobile des start up des pme des
deux pays
quel regard vous portez sur cet
écosystème que vous avez entre autour de
vous alors on a la chance alors déjà le
technocentre dans sa dans sa surface à
ses casiers mon gros comme la défense
donc on voit bien l'impact que cela peut
avoir et compris d'ailleurs en matière
d'environnement et ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose sur laquelle je m'engage
personnellement c'est également protéger
notre environnement mais également
vis-à-vis des citoyens autour de nous
c'est également à maintenir des
relations importantes avec tout
l'écosystème puisqu'on peut comme vous
le disiez trouver des partenaires autour
de nous et à premières en premier lieu
évidemment la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec
laquelle mon prédécesseur avait beaucoup
de contacts et avec lesquels je vais
maintenir cette relation de proximité là
mais réduit en cours bien sûr puisque
beaucoup de nos salariés peuvent être
également des habitants de ces villes
environnantes y compris guyancourt donc
c'est très important en fait de nourrir
ses traces et ses relations et partager
en fait le possible et développer
finalement un tissu économique qui pour
nous est important
merci elle est alliée terrien directrice
des établissements renault et directrice
du technocentre renault de guyancourt